- So you met your boyfriend
on The Office, I know him.
- I did.
- So like
who made the first move?
- You know what, I invited
him to my comedy act
'cause I, but I invited
all guys on the crew,
like it wasn't, I know right,
come on, right, Noelle.
It was just like, I don't know
and then he asked me out
when he came to the show.
So like literally we
are kind of Jim and Pam,
like 'cause we worked together
- Yeah.
- and it took a while for, I mean,
we didn't start dating until
the end of season two, so.
- Oh, wow, so that's a lot of like
- Yeah.
- you getting to know each
other without any pressure.
- Yeah, I mean
he wasn't there every day,
- Yeah.
- but he's hanging out
in the fake men's room off the kitchen
on the side of the office.
Do you guys know where that is, right?
Anyway.
- No, I love that you hung out
with a guy that hung out
in a fake men's room.
(laughing)
That's awesome.
- And my dad owns a bar,
I have a great life.
- Did you, it's interesting.